Acola, our family, my husband and I, we have three children and our story with Dr. Connor started
about eight years ago. And our son who was three at the time, he had since he was a baby had
multiple symptoms, he would just stop breathing and he would get transported to the hospital.
They didn't know it was wrong. They thought cancer, they thought because of things but couldn't find
anything for sure. And so we had heard about Dr. Connor's and after talking about it, praying about it,
just I just knew for sure we were supposed to go. And so that's what started our journey with Dr.
Connor's and for our son Isaac it wound up being our snake poisoning. And so it which cost a lot
of symptoms for our son and Dr. Connor's was able to detox him and all those symptoms have gone
including a severe peanut allergy which normally doesn't leave. So I no longer carry epipans and
his leaky gut is healed. And so that just kind of progressed into us just really starting to understand
Dr. Connor's and the alternative medicine and just seeing firsthand how that could change
our children's health. And so as time went on we started to deal with our daughters and I actually
we got Lyme disease and living in the north was a Minnesota. There's a lot of Lyme and a lot of
ticks. So again I just automatically chose Dr. Connor's and he has definitely definitely helped us.
We have had it several times and so that has really helped. And in the course of time I did develop
cancer and breast cancer and so our course of treatment was Dr. Connor's the whole way. We decided
that that was just the best route to go. And it has been a really good thing for us. It's
we have a shared faith in God and so to be able to incorporate things that heal the body along with
things spiritually that build us up and that speak truth into our lives and rely on God for that
healing and just for day-to-day living and knowing that we are truly in God's hands. That has been
just such a rewarding journey for us and we have just come to love and respect Dr. Connor's so much
and as far as cancer for me I am doing really really well. I feel really well. There have been
a couple times where I haven't felt as well come in and Dr. Connor's to some more checking and
tweak some things and it's always within a couple of weeks I am so much stronger again and feeling
really well. So we're really really thankful, really thankful for that. And we've even used
Dr. Connor's for some of the food sensitivities that seem to naturally come with our food
system and our source of the sources of food in our country so that's just he's been a real help
to us to help clear up our own wondering about different things and so he's just been a huge
encouragement to us. So I would just highly recommend Dr. Connor's for our family. It's been a
blessing and we have absolutely no regret. We just have felt so blessed to have an opportunity
to go to someone like Dr. Connor's. Wonderful. Thank you.